uh today it's about foucault's pendulum
which you'll see in
local science museums foucault in 1851
found that if you set a long pendulum
going and he did this
according to my michelin guide in the
cellar of his uh
building
he had a very long steel wire and he
swung it backwards in forwards he found
that if he was very careful the plane at
which this swings rotates slowly about
the central direction it rotates and
this is due to the movement of the earth
later on he showed it in the pathfinder
in paris
and it was a sensation it has been
copied all by all the science museums
so you said a pendulum coming from the
ceiling downwards and here's my arm
acting as the pendulum and i have a bob
on the end a heavy weight and this
pendulum swings backwards and forwards
you've all seen pendulum only this one
does something different it starts to
rotate around rotate around not at this
speed it would take 24 hours at the
north or south pole to actually turn
around completely and come back into the
same direction excuse me brady i'm
showing you my back side but this is
just part of the demonstration and to
illustrate how he did the experiment i'm
going to do a very simple minded
demonstration of how you would do it
here is
my bob it should be a spherical thing
but i can't be bothered to find one or
george couldn't find one but then george
is wonderful so i don't want to rude
about him then i'm going to fix it with
a bit of string and support it from a
suspension there the thing is if i were
to let this go
and give it a little jitter it would go
around in an oval path and i want to
avoid that so the trick is
as used by mussier foucault leon fuco
is to put a bit of string there i i'm
going to set fire to this there's still
some vibration there but i would leave
it to go and then suddenly it goes and
then you get it going in a plane the
reason i use fire was if i used a pair
of scissors i'd jog the bit of string if
i do it with a flame it cuts through and
there's no jittery motion either way so
you get it going in a plane now somebody
did this experiment
at the south pole a man called alan
baker
um and he tried to set it up he had 30
meters of wire everything was perfect
only there's the treaty of the antarctic
which for bed
forbids the use of flames so he couldn't
use this trick and he spent ages trying
to get it to go right but eventually he
managed to get it more or less perfect
and found that it actually goes round in
24 hours plus or minus something at the
south pole it goes around the opposite
way in the southern hemisphere compared
to the normal northern hemisphere
there's one thing that goes wrong with
this experiment as you can see the the
amplitude of this oscillation changes
with time
it decreases because of the friction of
the air and you make the system bigger
and there's still friction of the air so
this guy found that at the south pole
after about a couple of hours it died
away too much so he had to do his
measurements in about 20 minutes if you
make the thing much longer
and put it in a museum like the parthian
you will find that it
still decays in a couple of hours
four or five maybe and so
either you set it running for a certain
length of time and see that it will
rotate for a certain angle and then have
a big fanfare and start it again and
burn it with another bit of match or
you put a little motor in the top and
give it a little jiggle
and put energy in at the top which is
somehow cheating because you're actually
pushing the damn thing and you have to
make sure you push it in a way which is
not going to cause a talk
so that's the way it's done in a lot of
museums if you see it in a museum
there's not much to see you go in and 10
minutes later it's hardly move you go in
two hours later and you'll see a big
difference so it's one of those things
you should see in when you go into the
science museum and see when you come out
and you'll see the effect so let me
illustrate what would happen if you
could see it 10 hours later we keep this
going it starts off and it will
oscillate backwards and forwards with
this plane and now if you were to come
back say 10 hours later and it was still
going
you would see it with respect to the lab
moving in this direction
and if you come back even later it will
be moving in this plane and it will
continually rotate in its plane as time
progresses provided you can keep this
thing oscillating so i have here my
lovely demonstration of the north and
south pole so if we take this off and
imagine putting a pendulum here swinging
backwards and forwards at the north pole
because the earth is rotating i can't
remember which way it rotates you can
see as far as this pendulum is concerned
the earth is rotating underneath
my finger
and so the plane of this oscillation
remains constant
and this pendulum doesn't know that
there's the earth there apart from the
gravity that's pulling it down it has no
force pulling it in one direction or the
other
at this point and as far as it's
concerned it's just moving in a station
in an inertial frame that is a frame
which is stationary with respect to all
the moving stars around it and the earth
is moving
it will work at the poles and the period
of the pendulum
will be 24 hours because the earth
rotates roughly at 24 hours
if you come at the equator the earth is
not rotating about the equator it's not
rotating that way round it just going
around like that and there is no effect
at the equator if you come to let's say
great britain or france or even the
united states of america
then you have a latitude say of 45 50
degrees and the period of the pendulum
will go up to 32 or 33 hours so it
becomes longer and as you get towards
the equator the period gets towards
infinity and and when i talk about the
period what i don't mean is the period
of this pendulum going backwards and
forwards i mean the period which the
plane of this rotates around
what's happening is the earth is
imperceptibly moving under our feet
very slowly and you can't notice it and
why it was such a sensation foucault
demonstrated to people that they could
actually observe the rotation of the
earth
it's pretty cool isn't it
yeah i thought i was dead clever of fuco
i mean it's
it's something i wouldn't have thought
of and whenever i try and think about it
you have to have this idea that there
are stars out there which give you a
reference frame and the pendulum keeps
in a straight line with respect to the
stars but even that's not good enough i
talk to my friend and say all these
stars and galaxies are moving around and
then they say well when we're put in a
corner the astronomers say there's the
cosmic background radiation and if
you're in the right reference frame that
is isotropic in all directions
but
i just like the simple-minded
explanation